What do Nintendo, Garmin, Anheuser-Busch InBev and Bloomberg all have in common?
They all are recognizable brands,...
...but what you might not know is that all of them have been founded or run by billionaires.
Billionaires you may never have heard of.
Hiroshi Yamauchi from Japan turned Mario and Luigi into household names.
Yamauchi is credited with turning Nintendo from a small card company...
...into a multibillion dollar video console entertainment system.
The former president is currently the largest individual shareholder.
For a lot of these people, they're just normal people, down-to-earth people...
...and they want to keep their families and their children out of the limelight...
...so they actively avoid giving interviews...
...and that's part of the reason why you haven't heard of them.
Then, there's Brazilian beer brewing billionaire, Jorge Paulo Lemann.
A strategic investment in 1989...
...allowed this billionaire to have a controlling stake in Anheuser-Busch InBev,...
...which produces famous global brands like Stella, Becks and of course Budweiser.
And everyone knows billionaire Mike Bloomberg,...
...but his cofounder Thomas Secunda flies under the radar.
Thomas Secunda was more of a programmer and he helped to build the prototype...
...that became the now ubiquitous Bloomberg terminal.